we have Sheriff Mark Daniels with us
right now the Cochise County Arizona
Sheriff
um Sheriff there are more important
things to do that's essentially the
message from the president what did you
make of that
well Neil to say I'm disappointed is an
understatement again President Biden has
placed big business over Public Safety
National Security and human life on our
borders my County alone we're seeing
huge impacts negative impacts we're on a
slippery slope we've done this for 20
months and let me just say this to you
too Neil National sheriffs have reached
out to President Biden and asked to meet
with him both at my state and uh in
Washington DC he has not even answered
our letters he has not prioritized he
has not engaged this border we feel
abandoned down here on Southern border
and it continues uh with the president
being in my own State not coming down
here it's a slap as a disrespect and uh
it's a personally it's just a disgrace
you know I'm sure if I it it I could see
how you would look at this as a slot
because he's less than 100 miles from
you
um and whatever the importance I'm not
minimizing importance of semiconductor
multi-billion dollar commitments to be
built in this country on the part of
everyone from time on Sunday conductor
and apple and a host of others big news
but bigger news is what's happening in
your neck of the woods uh uh are you
concerned that avoiding an opportunity
like this to go to the Border he never
will
well and that's that's the issue he has
not been to the Border as our president
the president who has a oath of office
mandate to secure our borders Protect
America what message do we take here in
law enforcement on the border from State
local and federal that are working so
hard to keep our community safe keep
this country safe and our president has
failed to gauge to protect us let alone
Americans on on in this country uh Neil
there's just no good answer to this one
except for the fact it's continued
neglect uh intentional avoidance with
intended consequences so it's tough for
us down here to see that today yes
yet you know it's remarkable uh to me at
least a sheriff and you know your state
far better than I ever will is that
Democrats swept and their elections were
certified all the way from governor of
course Mark Kelly we elected the United
States Senate I'm I'm just wondering if
this is as big an issue as you've
clearly pointed out and others will
agree with you it's a huge one given the
fact that you know three million plus
has now gone through the Border hundreds
of thousand more gotaways and yet it
isn't it didn't seem to resonate among
Arizona voters
what we have is we have National
politics playing out in communities
every day and you look in my County
alone I believe we were 60 percent red
in my County on the vote so people
recognize it we just did a survey here
on another issue going on in our County
uh immigration is the number one concern
in my County as a sheriff I recognize
that you look around my State uh the red
States all recognize it the blue states
don't unfortunately uh we are getting
very lonely down here in Cochise County
and many other border communities as
politics is infected Public Safety and
that's what I'm talking about Public
Safety National Security and the
thousands of people have died on the
Southwest border
you know what's remarkable and you can
help me with this as well as you often
do and I appreciate it Sheriff the
president's spokesman alluded to the
fact that the president initially
offered comprehensive you know
immigration reform I assume she was
referring to as taking office I don't
recall that
Neil I don't either I mean I I wish like
to see something that had a border
some border immigration Mission attached
to it come out of the White House I
don't recall when she said that but she
also made another comment that was
alarming to me that if he came down here
it'd be political well this is reality
and and once again we hide under the
politic the political umbrella instead
of the reality of life and this is what
I'm talking about and I speak to you and
other media is let's get back to reality
do we have a drug problem in this
country yes we do we know where it's
coming from we have people dying on the
border do we have a quality of life
issue on our borders because it's porous
right now and open yes we do let's get
back to reality and that's where I push
Sheriff incredible thank you for taking
the time again my friend
thank you Neil appreciate you be having
me hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else